I'm in yev like a city in Sweden about a
hundred miles north of Stockholm and
every year they have a Christmas
tradition build an enormous goat out of
straw and put it in the town square
it is called the yeah Blake goat there
is a second Christmas tradition you have
way burning the goat down it's not like
Guy Fawkes night in Britain or Burning
Man in California where something is
built to be burned down burning this
down is awesome it is completely illegal
and genuinely the people who make the
giant straw goat do not want their giant
straw goat to be burned down giant straw
goats are expensive it's just that in
the 50 years that a 10 meter high mostly
unprotected goat made of extremely
flammable straw has been put up here the
goat has only survived 12 times usually
it's burned down in 1976 it was hit by a
car in 1979 it was burned down before it
even made it here in 1988 you could
place a vet on what the goat would burn
down at least you could until the goat
burned down in 2001 an American tourist
burned it down and when he was arrested
he said that his friends had told him
that burning the goat was an entirely
legal tradition he got a couple of weeks
in jail didn't get his cigarette lighter
back and left Sweden without paying a
large fine
in 2005 vandals dressed as Santa Claus
and gingerbread man fired
a burning arrow at the goat and burned
it down in 2006 the city fireproof the
goat it burned down in 2009 there were
webcam setup to spot vandals those
cameras were taken offline with a
denial-of-service attack just before the
goat burned down in 2011 they sprayed
the goat with water to form a protective
coat of ice it burned down its massive
and it is made of tinder it is really
really easy to run down this goat now
the local fire brigade are only two
minutes away and sometimes they win are
in 2014 despite three arson attempts the
goat did survive and now it is 2016 the
goat was put up just a few days ago and
as I record this it's still that all it
takes to create a tradition like this is
the same thing happening for a few years
in a row this goat wouldn't be famous if
it didn't burn down I wouldn't be here
this would just be us
or local display but every year someone
takes the risk of a fine and a criminal
record and time in jail to try and burn
down someone else's hard work probably
because they're drunk when they do it
and that strange
in the shadows battle that almost sitcom
like plot gets the world interested and
sends a few tourists to a fairly obscure
Swedish city place he bats a quick
update I'm back in London just landed at
Heathrow Airport literally a few hours
after filming that the goat has already
been burned to the ground
[Music]
you
you
you
you